[Music]
all right Tyler I make stuff I'm gonna
show you what I keep in my possession my
inhaler Wow yeah I've asthma
I have [ __ ] fat guy lungs it sucks
because I'm really skinny I have a man
purse little wallet thing here with
flowers on it I don't like a lot of [ __ ]
in my pockets so it's as minimal as it
could get those people off am I gonna
pay for stuff
I'm very manly way don't always randomly
have a big chunk of 24 karat gold I
think with the green amethyst on the
bottom I bought this in Brazil from a
father/daughter duo always carry [ __ ]
with me just like that reminds me of my
kid or people I don't have any pockets
with stuff in them so we'll go through
my bag I live in LA so Wayfarers that my
name on them there customer I always
have meat on me I know this looks like
no weed right now but there's more where
that came from
told me take our song
you see there's some pounds in them
I'm worldwide this is my wallet that I
got as a present I also got this chain
as a present as well and Jesse Joe gave
this to me
so like I just always keep it with me
this isn't in my pocket I'm normally oh
if I could fit this in my pocket I would
but that's so it makes me look like a
skater I carry a sharpie around because
I like to write on my hand of my to do
list
tattooed these pants I wear nothing in
the pocket because they were made by
Japanese men and a mr. Nagaya and he
pulled me aside he said you cannot wear
anything in the pocket I normally have
my pocket knife as I said I don't have
that today was afraid you'd take it from
me at the door but I do however have my
VW bus keys why I was late though
because they run a little slower so and
I would ask what I know I'm ready to
clear my pockets I feel really
successful if I have nothing I guess you
know if you're in New York and detective
her or you need a credit card that's
about it
[Music]